-How are you doing
with all that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My old man
would have hated this.
What are you doing?
Go after the Marcy Killers
as the bad guys.
Leave your fellow cops alone.
-Elliot, that was
a different time.
That was your father.
You had to go along
to get along.
-He's a tough-ass.
Not perfect...
but he's a good cop.
-Elliot.
My friend.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're doing the right thing.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Mariska Hargitay,
Christopher Meloni.
-I didn't realize that.
It came out.
-You don't watch my show?
-Must be --
-Hey, not now, Seth,
we're talking.
-No, I understand.
-[ Laughs ]
I never saw that scene.
-You never saw that scene?
-I said I didn't realize
it came out so sexy.
-Oh.
-And he said,
"You never watch my show?"
And I go like this, "No."
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice
that you have a friendship
that could be that honest.
-He never watched me
after he left.
-Did you not think
you were acting it sexy?
-No.
-Really?
Then you have a lot of
inadvertent sexiness,
I'm sorry to tell you.
-Oh.
-What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Speaking of --
-Don't hate me 'cause I'm sexy.
-I want to congratulate you.
Christopher, you've been
recently anointed ---
I hope that's the right term --
a zaddy.
Am I saying that right?
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, thank you.
And this is a council of zaddies
that gives you this honor?
-A coterie.
-A coterie?
-Yes, and it's
a worldwide organization.
-For those who don't
know the term, what is --
what is a zaddy,
and what are your duties?
-I think it's
an elderly gentleman
who kind of exudes
a certain athleticism,
maybe sex appeal.
-Yeah.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think this was the photo
you submitted to the coterie.
-Yes, yes.
-Not too shabby.
-Wow.
-And they insisted
that I put my hands on the plate
just for show.
-Oh, so you didn't need
your hands?
[ Laughter ]
-What, what?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-By the way, in case
anybody was wondering --
-Yeah, okay.
-You okay?
-Hey, guys, what am I, then?
[ Laughter ]
-I am --
I think you only wanted
to show that
because you were so worried
a fan was gonna be waiting
outside your house,
being like,
"Why wasn't my doll --
Why did you show only two
of the three dolls?"
-But can I tell you something?
This fan made one for me,
Mariska,
and then one for Olivia,
so I got two for one.
-Wow.
Hey, I want to congratulate you,
as well, Christopher,
on your success,
because you recently posted --
you went to St. Stephen's School
in Virginia.
This was a letter home.
And I just --
Maybe you were not destined
for success early on.
We highlighted, "While
Christopher's academic record
has been satisfactory --"
congratulations on that --
"you should know that we're
very seriously concerned
about the number of demerits
he has accumulated."
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-Does that surprise you,
Mariska, that maybe he was --
-No.
-Really, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Seems like a demerit collector
to you?
-Well, he beats to his own drum.
-Okay, that's right.
-Would you say that's fair?
-I think
that's a very accurate --
-Beats to his own drum.
-Is it nice to have a new sort
of entry in the franchise,
where you get to both
have crossover episodes,
but also do a new kind of show?
-It really is.
it's very liberating.
I appreciate
how we tell stories.
you know, and
anytime I get to work with her,
I think you would agree
that it's really --
it really is
special and magical,
and it's a gift.
It's like,
"Oh, she's coming on?"
You know, it's very nice.
-It's really cool.
And I really appreciate you guys
making the time together
with us today.
It was wonderful.
-Thank you.
-And now you're
leaving the dolls for me,
or are you taking them?
-Well, I feel like
you should have one.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys, give it up
one more time.
Mariska Hargitay,
Christopher Meloni, everybody.
"Law & Order: SVU" airs
Thursday nights at 9:00,
followed by
"Law & Order: Organized Crime,"
right here on NBC.